well all right i hope everybody had a
wonderful mother's day yesterday those
winds were outrageous and i know
that you had to check that you had to
battle them if you were outdoors at all
celebrating mom now the winds have
calmed down a lot the dust has settled
down a lot but boy they were it was
crazy yesterday it was just a dust bowl
in southern nevada and las vegas
temperatures much cooler this morning in
the 50s
friday morning at this time we had
temperatures in the 70s for morning lows
49 at mountain's edge 47 at red rock and
look at the 20s up there at kyle canyon
we're looking for a high today that was
near our morning low on friday we were
96 for the high friday afternoon we're
going to be about 20 degrees cooler
today in the mid 70s definitely below
normal sunrise was 5 40 in sunset at 7
35. you know i've talked about all the
records in may are in the triple digits
we're going to be reaching for those
extra hot numbers by the end of the
eight day forecast
the gusts were tremendous last night
around 8 30 red rock 75 miles an hour
mountain's edge 65 mile per hour wind
gusts there was a weather spotter said
that visibility was down below a hundred
yards
at times yesterday with those strong
winds and mountains edge water street
downtown henderson 63 mile an hour wind
gusts and this was about 7 30 yesterday
evening north las vegas 50 plus it's all
because of this very strong low which is
now moved up into the northern plains
there's a secondary low with this cold
front which the cold front has helped
turn the winds to the northwest we still
have red flag warnings fire weather
danger forests issued for another day
now from 10 to 10 a.m to 8 p.m and
that's all across arizona and into new
mexico new mexico is still suffering
terribly with the wildfire conditions
there this is the
hemet's fire as well as the calf canyon
fire they have now converged burning
over 175
000 acres 1500 firefighters are there
trying to put this huge fire out but the
wind and the dry conditions are just so
much to battle
it is terrible there east of santa fe
and albuquerque oh my goodness las vegas
new mexico in the northeast part of the
state all right so be careful with
anything please that could start a fire
mid 70s we'll still have northwest
breezes to maybe 30 miles an hour in the
afternoon another couple of pieces of
energy blow by us tomorrow and wednesday
southwest winds tuesday wednesday 71 on
wednesday our coolest day of the week
then look how the temperatures ramp up
to our first triple digits of the year
maybe as soon as sunday into monday wow